[Music]
celebrating europe day shaping
tomorrow's european union
the conference on the future of europe's
co-chairs handed over its final report
with 49 proposals containing more than
300 measures for a better eu
we are once again
at a defining moment of european
integration and no suggestion for change
should be off limits
whatever process is required in order
for us to get there should be embraced
this is the moment to answer europe's
call this is our time
with events across the eu and here in
parliament the conference was a
year-long exercise in participatory
democracy
at its center european citizens they
generated hundreds of ideas on climate
change migration and health on rights
democracy and the eu's role in the world
areas brought sharply into focus by the
war in ukraine
i want to give a very special message to
our ukrainian friends and families
the future of europe
is also your future
the future of our democracy is also the
future of your democracy
president from the lion has promised
proposals based on the conference's
conclusions in september
of the major changes in the pipeline
[Applause]
the conference was the first exercise of
its kind in eu history the hope is it
won't be the last
the antigua conference
foreign
[Music]
you